today I want to talk about something a
bit unusual that was discovered a little
while ago it's called it's got a funny
name it's called Hanny's Voorwerp I may
be pronouncing that completely wrong any
of our Dutch viewers can correct me
this is an object that was discovered by
accident as many of the the most
exciting astronomical discoveries are
made and it was actually discovered by a
member of the public a schoolteacher in
Holland named Hanna van Arkel and so the
name is Hanny's Voorwerp
and Vorwerk I understand means Dutch for
objects so this is Hanna's object and
that's what it looks like it's a bit of
a funny-looking thing so one of the
things that we do as astronomers is we
take pictures it's one of the most basic
things that we can do and even now even
when we have digital images from great
big telescopes we still get a lot of
information by looking at them with our
eye so typical thing for an astronomer
like myself to do would be to cycle
through maybe hundreds or even thousands
of images of individual objects so this
is from my own survey so these are
images from the Hubble Space Telescope
here's a beautiful galaxy that's we're
seeing it's a disc like our own Milky
Way but we're seeing an edge on and
we'll see a huge variety of different
kinds of objects great big round ones
things with spiral arms things that
might call that a train wreck you know
might be the collision of two galaxies
something that's been really disruptive
so even though we have automated
routines to gather some of this
information we can teach a computer to
do this those automated routines are
still not perfect and there's still a
lot to be gained by using our AI brain
system which is really good at picking
out particular patterns or particular
features so in my own research I may
have gone through probably about four or
five thousand of these images recording
whether there have spiral arms whether
they're round whether they have bars
whether they're all messed up and
together with a team of maybe about
seven or eight other people we could
cover in my survey about six or seven
thousand galaxies with each one being
done a couple of times to make sure that
we agree on our classification but what
about when you have a survey like the
Sloan Digital Sky Survey where you
actually have millions of galaxies and
that's far too many galaxies for any
sane individual to look through one by
one so in this case a project called
Galaxy Zoo has enlisted members of the
public to help with this project Galaxy
Zoo is is is a project that I'm not
involved with but is close to our hearts
here in Nottingham because our
collaborator our colleague Steven
Bamford down the hall plays a key role
in this project and they've enlisted
literally hundreds of thousands of
people members of the general public
schoolchildren amateur astronomers
people off the street tell me and me and
Brady of course to help with this with
this problem how many galaxies are you
looked up I did about 20 oh I don't
think you're up there in the top and
this is the Galaxy Zoo webpage at Galaxy
Zoo org so a Galaxy Zoo participant once
they register and log in they do the
same thing they do they are presented
with pictures of galaxies and they look
at them and they're asked a very
specific set of questions or criteria to
really narrow down the focus of the
science and all of those classifications
are combined in a very clever
statistical way and project has shown
that these classifications are as robust
as the classifications of done by
professional astronomers like ourselves
and in the first leg of the project as I
said they had 150,000 people classifying
a million galaxies submitting 50 million
classifications I couldn't speak for all
of them but a lot of it is a real you
get a real hands-on connection with with
the actual science with the images the
images themselves are beautiful you're
looking at spectacular pictures of
galaxies collections of hundreds of
billions of stars billions and billions
of light-years away and then there's
always this the seed this possibility
that you're going to uncover something
that nobody else has
and that's exactly what happened in the
case of Hannah's rule so Hannah van
Arkel the schoolteacher from Holland was
a participant in the Galaxy Zoo project
and she she uncovered this strange
object I think she posted on the Galaxy
Zoo forms to ask if anyone else knew
what this was no one could explain it
and it became an object of interest it
became something out of the ordinary
something unexpected and that's always
what we like to go and follow up so what
you're seeing here is several we'll lots
of galaxies there's this one big galaxy
here which you can see has hints of
spiral arms there's another companion
galaxy next to it but what we're
interested in is this green object here
and this is Hanny's Voorwerp
so it's an irregular shape that already
tells us there's something strange about
this object and in the color scheme that
we are shown here it's bright green so
it's very different in color from any of
the other galaxies around it and that
means it's emitting light at a
particular frequency and at a
particularly narrow frequency so as I
said this was a puzzle it wasn't
immediately obvious what this object was
members of the Galaxy Zoo project and
other astronomers around the world have
since followed it up with many different
telescopes at different wavelengths
trying to find out as much as they could
about it what they've determined is that
it doesn't have any stars of its own
it's mostly gas and dust it's probably
the remnants of a little tiny galaxy
that's been tightly pulled apart by
interacting gravitationally with this
much larger galaxy but we might not
normally see that because the gas or the
dust would within the absence of stars
wouldn't be very bright what they think
has happened is that something has
dumped a lot of energy into this gas its
ionized it and it's made it glow at this
particular narrow wavelength that object
could be something like a quasar so a
supermassive black hole accreting
material and spewing out tons
tons of energy but there's no smoking
gun in this picture at any wavelengths
we can't or they can't actually see the
candidate quasar it may be very very
hidden it may be hidden in the center of
this galaxy here but another possibility
which is very intriguing is that it was
spewing out all this energy but stopped
and we've had enough time for that that
energy to reach Penny's warp ionize that
gas and make it glow but that gap could
be as long as a hundred thousand years
so what we could be seeing here is
what's called a light echo of a quasar
that's now dormant it's now dead but we
can still see what kind of effects its
had on these objects around it